am sonntag ist bundestagswahl
sie ist so spannend wie lange nicht mehr
der ausgang völlig offen
und trotzdem werden wieder millionen
menschen zu hause bleiben werden nicht
wählen
2017 waren es mehr als 14 millionen
14 millionen gäbe es eine fiktive partei
der nichtwähler wäre sie stärkste kraft
geworden
woran liegt das warum verzichten so
viele auf ihr recht mitzubestimmen aus
frust desinteresse resignation wer sind
die nichtwählerinnen und nichtwähler
das wollte ich wissen
über das zdf und die sozialen medien
habe ich einen aufruf gestartet warum
ich nicht zur wahl gehe
tausende haben mir geantwortet
in meinem ganzen leben bin ich immer zu
allen wahlen gegangen geändert hat sich
nie etwas
die politik ist das spielzeug der
lobbyisten und das wird auch so bleiben
deswegen lasse ich das lieber
wählen zu gehen bedeutet in deutschland
mittlerweile die wahl zu haben zwischen
pest und cholera
wen soll man denn wählen keine partei
setzt sich für uns auto normalos 1
einige die mir geschrieben haben habe
ich in den letzten wochen besucht
für die zukunft grafik auch dort gesagt
ist das ein grund die komplette politik
abzulehnen find ich schon er kümmert
sich um meine belange meine belange sind
in der politik aktuell nicht vertreten
und ich habe ihre fragen ihren unmut an
die politik weiter getragen
die jungen haben das gegenteilige gefühl
dass politik eher für die älteren
gemacht werden er hat das gefühl ist
aber falsch muss man widersprechen
[Musik]
meine reise führt mich zuerst nach
bruchsal
demokratie heißt es so schön lebt vom
engagement vom mitmachen demokratie ist
eine aufgabe für uns alle das alles weiß
thomas andere
nicht auch willkommen in der zukunft
willkommen in der zukunft
er war immer wählen er war sogar viele
jahre mitglied der spd aber jetzt sagt
er ist schluss
auf jeden fall alles
andere ist 63 in bruchsal leitet er ein
innovationszentrum dass die zukunft der
güter logistik entwirft sein job titel
tomorrow coach anderer sie nennen sich
tomorrow coach was macht man als tumor
coach genau ich fliege mit meinen kunden
in die zukunft einfach zu gucken was
können wir möglicherweise in der zukunft
sehen und das was wir dort sehen das
versuchen wir dann als grundlage zu
nehmen um die gegenwart zu entwickeln
sie haben mir geschrieben dass sie nach
gefühlt 50 jahren vom politischen
mitdenker zum überzeugten nichtwähler
geworden sind wie ist es dazu gekommen
wir kommen ist es eigentlich dazu und
als ich ich sage jetzt mal wir sind
jetzt in der zweiten jahr an demi und
wir wissen immer noch nicht wie man
schüler unterrichten können also das ist
für mich unvorstellbar und als
unternehmer jeder unternehmer muss
vorausschauen und wenn ich dann in die
politik der einblick dann habe ich
einfach ein ungutes gefühl
es gibt keine strategie und es gibt kein
voraussehen des handelns sondern es ist
eben immer das fahren auf sicht wir
kommen von krise zu krise wir hatten
jetzt der pandemie dann haben wir eine
naturkatastrophe
weil man eben keine plan geht keine
strategie keine vision hat um diese
aufgaben auch wirklich zu bewältigen
also haben das gefühl nicht nur bei der
pandemie jetzt bei der korona pandemie
sondern ganz generell bei der politik
ich habe das generell war der politik
wenn man sich heute die parteiprogramme
anguckt das sind doch keine entwürfe für
die zukunft das ist wie wenn sie zwei
zentimeter über die gegenwart hinaus
schauen wenn da in einem parteiprogramm
drinsteht wir wollen elektromobilität
fördern dann ist es ja schon fast
vergangenheit weil wir das ja schon
machen also diese diese dieser blick in
wirklich in 2050 dass wir alles nicht
gemacht
weitblick probleme nicht immer erst dann
angehen wenn sie uns schon vor die füße
gefallen sind
anderer baut an der logistik der zukunft
einen autonom fahrenden roboter soll
online bestellungen in wohngebiete
ausliefern ein paketbote der zukunft
wenn man so viel
weltweiten wünschen es sich so viele
menschen die nicht wählen können wählen
zu können das recht zu haben wir haben
das recht müssen wir dieses recht nicht
nutzen doch wir müssen das grundsätzlich
nutzen ich habe das selbst nur 60 jahre
lang genutzt ich bin immer zur wahl
gegangen hab immer gewählt aber ich muss
auch eine ausgangssituation wählen
können die mir wirklich verspricht dass
sich das ändert aber stärken sie damit
nicht die extremen parteien also
vielleicht gerade die parteien die noch
weniger an die zukunft denken oder die
eine
verquere zukunftsvision haben nein ich
glaube eher das gegenteil ist der fall
ich glaube jedenfalls nicht dass damit
die rechten strukturen oder
undemokratische strukturen gefördert
werden sondern eher dadurch weil auf
regierungsseite nicht die richtigen
entscheidungen getroffen werden sollen
kann handeln entsteht wenn die menschen
die orientierung hätten wenn die
menschen das vertrauen hätten würden sie
sicher nicht zu nichtwählern entwickeln
also ich glaube der nichtwähler ist ja
sozusagen das ergebnis dessen was auf
politischer seite schiefläuft
nicht wählen als protest als zeichen
nicht einverstanden zu sein mit der
politik bei der bundestagswahl 2017
haben knapp ein viertel aller
wahlberechtigten nicht gewählt
also genau 14 millionen 712.000 144 mehr
als jede andere partei stimmen erhalten
hat
am größten war der anteil der
nichtwähler in der altersgruppe der 21
bis 24 jährigen jeder dritte von ihnen
ist 2017 nicht zur wahl gegangen
viele nachrichten die ich gerade über
instagram erhalten habe zeichnen ein
ähnliches bild immer mehr jüngere fühlen
sich von der politik nicht ernst und
nicht wahrgenommen
weiß mittlerweile auch nicht mehr wen
ich wählen soll machen doch eh alle
denselben jugend verachtende mill ganz
egal ob grüne spd cdu fdp winkel oder
sonst wären
meine altersgruppe wird von der politik
gerade in zeiten wie diesen quasi
missachtet und bleibt unerhört
[Musik]
in cottbus bin ich zu einem besonderen
event eingeladen zu einem politischen
speed dating die organisatorin von
newton sind davon überzeugt demokratie
braucht junge stimmen aber weil die von
der politik aus ihrer sicht viel zu
wenig gehört werden muss man sie erst
mal hörbar machen deshalb touren sie vor
der wahl quer durch deutschland und
sammeln die stimmen der jugendlichen und
jungen erwachsenen vor ort um sie so
auch zum wählen zu animieren
sie machen das mit anderen kreativen
formaten nicht mit stand und fähnchen
sondern eben mit einem politischen speed
dating
wie hast du dir das so viele menschen
gehen
also meinst du dass politik
fühlt sie sich als junger mensch genug
angesprochen von den parteien
nicht wirklich muss da wird mir angucken
die weltpolitik machen
mächtigkeit nicht sicher
gewesen corona phantom ii oder so hat
das junge menschen eher weniger ernst
genommen wurden und ich darf auch bei
anderen themen wie zum beispiel die
klimawandel uns weiter sie hat er das
gefühl dass sie interessen oder von
jungen menschen vor allen dingen halten
planeten oder eine umwelt ist haben sie
einfach nicht
zerstören wir getrennt vielen dank dass
ihr da wart weder
das problem in zahlen 73 prozent der
jungen menschen sind laut einer
aktuellen studie unzufrieden oder sogar
sehr unzufrieden damit wie die politik
ihre anliegen und interessen
berücksichtigt
einen von ihnen treffe ich an der
universität in bochum
simon bibel 24 studiert hier geschichte
und philosophie
er schrieb mir
mir persönlich sitzen zu viele politiker
in unternehmen und handeln somit in
deren interesse
simon die bundestagswahl steht angela
merkel tritt nach 16 jahren nicht mehr
an der wahlausgang ist ziemlich offen
was werden sie tun also ich werde
wahrscheinlich nicht zur wahl gehen
warum ich weil es so gewisse sachen der
politik nicht einfach komplett still was
zum beispiel also ich finde es schon
erschreckend das ist eigentlich mein
hauptargument das da so viel lobbyarbeit
gemacht hätte und dass da so viel
korruption gemacht wie zum beispiel die
pipeline nach al sawija und das ist ja
kein einzelfall das war dann ein guter
meter geldgeschäfte mit den masten man
sieht ja wohl geldgeschäfte werden kann
in die eigene tasche wird es gemacht von
einzelnen ja von einzelnen aber es ist
ja nicht nur ein es sind ja schon
mehrere also wenn jetzt einer sagen
würde es ist ein einziger der sich da
immer wieder die taschen vollmacht da
könnte man ja sagen okay das hat er
gemacht da haben wir entfernt und damit
ist schluss aber es kommt ja immer
wieder also und ich weiß ja sowieso was
kann ich nicht unterstützen es ist ja
jetzt kein phänomen das irgendwie 19
politiker in grub sind es sind ja
einzelne politiker das sind ja nicht
alle politiker ist das ein grund die die
komplette politik abzulehnen finde ich
schon so herr lindner hat er mal gesagt
dass es besser nicht zu regieren falsch
zu regieren und da kann man ja genau so
gut aussah ist es besser nicht zu wählen
falls zu wählen
was müsste passieren dass sie sagen okay
ich bin wieder dabei ich gehe wieder
wählen dass man wirklich die ernsten
themen die ist ja auch wirklich wichtig
sind vor allem der klimawandel das ist
wirklich ernst genommen wird und nicht
gesagt wird ja in 35 machen wir
irgendwas aber klimaschutz haben sich
jetzt viele parteien auf die fahnen
geschrieben warum wählen sie dann nicht
beispielsweise die grünen wenn
klimaschutz in wichtig jetzt richtig die
grünen hatten ja zum beispiel auch für
mich persönlich kein gutes bild
abgegeben beim hambacher forst dass der
gerodet wird finde ich da irgendwie so
ein bisschen kontrovers und deswegen ist
die ganze partei für sie unwählbar
ja ich habe einfach auch so ein bisschen
die sorge wenn dann größere entscheidung
anstehen das tier genau so klingen wie
alle anderen also ist politik nicht
kompromiss also ist das kommt gewiss
auch keine partei wo ich sage zu 100
prozent ist dass meine partei gibt es
glaube ich für niemanden richtig das ist
denke ich auch warum wählen sie nicht
einfach die partei die noch am ehesten
mit ihren überzeugungen übereinstimmt
das wäre die tierschutzpartei aber sie
haben ja nicht wirklich eine
realistische chance im bundestag zu
kommen und deshalb denke ich mir halt
auch kann ich auch den gang zur urne
sparen was wollen sie damit erreichen
dass wahrscheinlich damit erreichen also
einfach mal das interesse auch ein
bisschen irgendwie zeigen dass ich damit
nicht einfach stellen wie politik
gemacht wird in diesem land
[Musik]
ich gebe zu mit so pauschaler kritik an
der politik tue ich mich schwer
aber nicht nur simon hat das vertrauen
in politik verloren es zieht sich wie
ein grundrauschen durch viele
nachrichten die ich bekommen habe
warum sollte man jemandem die stimme
geben den man nicht vertrauen kann
viele die so geschrieben haben wollten
sich nicht mit mir treffen es ist ihnen
oft bei unangenehmen vor laufender
kamera zu sagen ich werde nicht
in schneverdingen einem luftkurort
mitten in der lüneburger heide bin ich
dagegen willkommen
ich habe das gefühl dass politik nach
wie vor für alte weiße männer gemacht
wird
ist das nur ein gefühl oder mehr was
jedenfalls stimmt 14 prozent der
wahlberechtigten sind unter 30 aber 38
prozent über 60
hallo ich bin ja im bereich freut mich
sehr
juli trat ist alleinerziehend bezieht
gerade hartz 4 und wohnt mit ihrem sohn
in diesem kleinen häuschen in einer
ferienhaussiedlung am rande der stadt
juli angeschrieben
politik wird nach wie vor für alte weiße
männer gemacht ja was haben sie damit
gemeint
dass sich die politik zu wenig um neue
wähler bemüht das thema bildung zum
beispiel
wird immer mal angerissen aber wirklich
passieren tut dann nichts thema bildung
thema ausbildung thema weiterbildung
thema keine ahnung was alle
juni prag ist gelernte bürokauffrau
sie würde aber gerne um schulen zur
erzieherin zum beispiel erzieherinnen
werden überall gesucht
[Musik]
aber weil sie schon eine abgeschlossene
ausbildung hat wird sie dabei vom amt
nicht unterstützt und auch wenn es hier
auf den ersten blick nicht so aussieht
mit dem kleinen häuschen in der
feriensiedlung mit dem schönen garten
alleinerziehende tragen seit jahren mit
das höchste armutsrisiko in deutschland
ohne dass sich daran etwas ändert
was würden sie sich den wünschen dass
sich darum gekümmert wird dass ich die
möglichkeit habe auch alleine meine
familie meine kleine familie zu ernähren
und sie haben nicht das gefühl dass es
irgendwie partei gibt die dafür sogar
ihre
macht das wütend ja
man ist ein bisschen hilflos
wer kümmert sich um meine belange meine
belange sind in der politik aktuell
nicht nicht vertreten und auch von
vielen anderen jüngeren leuten nicht
also sie fühlen sich von der politik
nicht gesehen
unterm strich sind viele die ich kenne
die allein erziehenden beziehen hartz iv
einfach weil sie nicht die möglichkeit
haben wieder in lohn und brot zu kommen
dann kann man sich ja immer noch mit
vorurteilen
rumärgern das hartz4 empfänger dumm sind
das hartz4 empfänger faul sind ist ja
auch ein gängiges klischee und ich ziehe
mich wieder zu der einen oder anderen
gruppe
juli trat kann gut verstehen warum so
viele nicht zur wahl gehen aber
mir wurde von kleinauf eigentlich
beigebracht dass das ein privileg ist in
einer demokratie zu leben und dass ich
kann mich nicht entscheiden gehe ich zur
wahl oder gehe ich nicht zum wahren ich
habe mich nur entscheiden wen ich wähle
so das habe ich von meinem papa somit
gegeben gekriegt sonst würde ich
wahrscheinlich aktuell auch sagen ich
gehe nicht wählen mein papa würde mich
dahin tragen zur not
ich habe keine erwartungshaltung mehr so
richtig also was ich die ersten jahre
dachte so
man bewirkt mit seiner stimme dass da
was passiert dass da was kommt dass ich
was in richtung meiner interessen
verändern würde das glaube ich gar nicht
mehr
dass man mit seiner stimme nichts mehr
bewirkt das glauben immer mehr
seit den 70er jahren singt mit wenigen
ausnahmen die wahlbeteiligung auf allen
ebenen bei kommunalwahlen welt oft fast
die hälfte nicht mehr aber wahr ist auch
im internationalen vergleich stehen wir
in deutschland immer noch ganz gut da
was mich aber viel wichtiger finde
menschen mit geringerem einkommen
schlechter bildung oder auch berufen
niedrigeren sozialen status gehen viel
seltener wählen als andere und das ist
eben nicht zwangsläufig so dass es kein
naturgesetz diese schere ist erst in den
letzten 30 jahren auseinander gegangen
warum ist das so das wollte ich wissen
auf meinen aufruf über das zdf und die
sozialen medien habe ich einen satz
immer wieder gelesen es ändert doch je
nicht
wenn jahrzehntelang politik für eine
kleine reiche oberschicht gemacht wird
dann braucht sich niemand über eine
geringe wahlbeteiligung zu wundern
wenn du mit deiner stimme in 40 jahren
nichts ändern warum sollte es bei dieser
wahl anders sein du wirst doch eh nicht
wahrgenommen
aus ober im westerwald erhielt ich diese
nachricht
es wird versprochen und versprochen was
das zeug hält und im grunde genommen
passiert nur dass die reichen werden
reicher und die armen ärmer
klaus schulten hat sie mir geschrieben
meine frau ist
gerade vorgegangen ist abgehauen
sind sie von mir geflüchtet hallo freut
mich sie kennenzulernen hallo vielen
dank
[Musik]
klaus schulten ist berufskraftfahrer
57 jahre alt ist sie haben mir
geschrieben ich bin ein ganz normaler
kleiner berufskraftfahrer ja genau die
ganz normale gruska verdienen mein
normales geld verdiene als normaler
berufskraftfahrer netto so um die 2000
euro als lohn für das ist hier weil
meine frau ja auch geld verdient oder
trendige geld bekommen kommen sie damit
hin mit dem geld meint man sieht ja ich
komme kommt zurecht natürlich logisch da
war aber
aber luxus kann ich mir nicht leisten da
nochmal so ja sie sind jetzt 57 ja
wissen sie schon wann sie in rente gehen
können sind so schnell wie möglich
laut arbeitsministerium wahrscheinlich
mit mittel mit 760
also das heißt in zehn jahren das
denkmal vom körperlichen erschüttert war
viel meditieren deftig sein wenn sie in
rente gehen wissen sie was ihnen dann
bleibt
ich habe vor vier jahren hat er zehn mal
drauf geguckt
ich habe es aufgegeben ich guck da nicht
mal drauf weil es ist das ist ein witz
weil
alles traurig
meine frau weiß habe ich habe da sie
sollten sollte es mir nicht sagen sie
wollen gar nicht müssen lernen
dass ich möchte gar nicht wissen weil es
ist es so wie ich es ist traurig traurig
haben sie angst ein bisschen angst davor
ja definitiv ich habe angst davor später
in die altersarmut abzudichten auf jeden
fall ja da habe ich
auf deutsch gesagt eine scheiße angst
soll ja für mich ist auch definitiv zu
spät um da haben mich jetzt noch
abzusichern hat für mich ist sagt zug
abgefahren auf deutsch gemacht und bin
die spirale so weitergeht
wenn ich spiele so weitergeht werde ich
beten und total fall wären bestimmt ja
ich würde es nicht hoffen ich will
hoffen dass ich mich irre über
viele jahre hat klaus scholten spd
gewählt aber die sagt er sei für
arbeitnehmer wie ihn nicht mehr da bei
den letzten beiden bundestagswahlen 2013
und 2017 ist er zu hause geblieben wurde
zum nichtwähler
jetzt will er der afg seine stimme geben
sie haben mir geschrieben dass sie die
afg wählen will warum was erwarten sie
von der fdp gehe davon aus dass die
anderen parteien bei endlich
wachgerüttelt werden also sie glauben
nicht dass die afg ihnen hilft sondern
dass es eher so eine art warnsignal an
die anderen parteien genau genau gut sie
sagen sie sind nicht recht aber wenn sie
die fdp wählen wählen sie eben eine
partei die mindestens mal zum teil
rechtsradikale lauten ja nicht
rechtsradikal
die
rechtsradikale ecke ist rechtsradikal
das ist ein rechter hat mir ist ein
rechter flügel der bioenergie ist ein
rechter flügel aber aber das nehmen sie
in kauf dass du dann nehme ich ihn
kaufen das dann eben auch rechte und
rechtsradikale menschen dadurch mit
gewählt werden von ihnen ja dass nämlich
das nämlich in kauf das nehme ich in
kauf dass ihnen das egal
na egal schon die hat doch das muss ich
schon sagen ja machen würde ich schon
sagen ja weil ich momentan wie ich schon
sagte parteikollegen partei ja wenn es
die fdp nicht geben würde würden sie
dann nicht zur wahl gehen ich glaub
schon her stück glaube ich wird nicht so
bald ich immer davor war ich eigentlich
immer bei der spd war eigentlich immer
war der spd ja wenn auch wir waren nicht
in der ddr ja okay und dann haben sie
zweimal nicht gewählt
und durch die afd sind sie jetzt wieder
zum wähler gewonnen
also wurden haben kann die politik an
die froh sein die auf die da ist welche
wieder zum bilder geworden
[Musik]
die wahlbeteiligung 2017 ist im
vergleich zu den tiefständen 2009 und
2013 wieder gestiegen und das lag auch
an der afg
polarisierte ein wahlkampf ist desto
höher ist auch die wahl bereitschaft
aber kann sich die politik damit
zufrieden geben haben die parteien die
nichtwähler die politik müden schlecht
zu lange ignoriert
ich bin in berlin mit einem verabredet
der die deutsche politik seit
jahrzehnten mitbestimmt wolfgang
schäuble er ist 1972 zum ersten mal in
den bundestag eingezogen nie war die
wahlbeteiligung in deutschland höher als
damals
91,1 prozent
eine zahl von der wir heute nur träumen
können
herr schäuble niedriger die
wahlbeteiligung desto sozial ungleicher
wird die wahl in den 80er jahren war die
gruppe der nichtwähler
noch ziemlich genau ein querschnitt der
gesellschaft das bis heute nicht mehr so
heute gehen vor allem die ärmeren
menschen nicht zur wahl hat die politik
sich um diese menschen nicht ausreichend
gekümmert
wahrscheinlich muss man sich noch mehr
um die menschen kümmern das ist schon
wahr viele menschen das ist im übrigen
ja überwiegend gar nicht ein problem
materieller not sondern ich hörte es
immer so diese armutsstatistiken ihr
habt ja auch meine zweifel
es geht den materiell geht es den
meisten menschen viel besser als es
vergleichbare menschen früher oder in
anderen teilen der welt geht aber das
gefühl in dieser gesellschaft nicht
dazuzugehören ausgegrenzt zu sein oder
nicht teilhaben zu können das ist das
große problem wenn immer mehr menschen
nicht zur wahl gehen und wenn die
wahlbeteiligung sozial unausgewogen ist
die gefährlich wie problematisch ist das
für eine demokratie
wenn es so wäre würde es auf die dörfer
ein problem für die demokratie niedrige
wahlbeteiligung sind wirklich schlecht
und deswegen tun wir auch als bundestag
ziemlich viel was na ja also wir haben
es mal den bürgerrat ausprobiert um neue
formen der beteiligung zu finden aber
wir machen unheimlich viele programme
wir laden viele kommen wir arbeiten
natürlich fahren wir bezug auf junge
menschen auf die kinder und schüler nur
es scheint ja nicht zu wirken also die
wahlbeteiligung geht ja eben seit
jahrzehnten ging sie hoch und wie sie
jetzt im 26 september sein wird das
wollen wir sie wissen auch warum die
wahlbeteiligung bei der letzten wahl
nach oben gegangen ist das weiß ich
nicht so genau lag vor allem daran ist
dass die afg viele nichtwähler an die
urne geholt hat und andere an die urne
gegangen sind um gegen die fdp zu wählen
ja wie auch immer sie ist gestiegen
[Musik]
es gibt eine zweite gruppe aus der
besonders viele nicht wählen gehen das
sind die jungen von den 21 bis 24
jährigen ist ein drittel 2017 nicht zur
wahl gegangen wie erklären sie sich das
ja offenbar weil sie noch nicht
hinreichend begriffen haben dass sie
etwas bewegen können und ihr seht ja
nicht ärmere und nicht nicht weniger
gebildete da muss man daran arbeitet mit
denen ich gesprochen habe sagen mehr
politik ist für meine belange nicht da
politik wird vor allem für ältere
gemacht denn die sind in der mehrzahl
die entscheiden wahlen muss mir ihnen
widersprechen
und muss ihnen sagen
politik wird vor allem für die jüngeren
gemacht die wir machen politik für die
zukunft haben sie was wir heute
entscheidend ist für mich nicht mehr so
furchtbar wichtig ich bin 79 die jungen
haben aber das gegenteilige gefühl dass
politik eher für die älteren gemacht
werden und es gibt würde ich aber falls
da muss man widersprechen klimapolitik
will beispiel klimapolitik so lange zu
wenig passiert ja das ist ja wahr
hinweist kann man das so vertreten aber
man muss dann wissen sie die junge
braucht noch widerspruch wenn wir den
jungen immer wenn wir hier einen jungen
immer sagen ihr habt recht erstritten
es ist überhaupt nicht junge brauchen
auch ein stückweit widerstand nur
zahlenmäßig haben sie natürlich die
jungen natürlich recht fast 40 prozent
sind über 60 nur knapp 15 prozent sind
unter 30 also die älteren entscheiden
natürlich die wahrheit ist das nicht ein
problem
ich kann daran der demographie nix
ändern
habe sich dann nicht wahr dass die
ältere nur für sich entscheiden
die älteren machen sich noch mehr sorgen
vielleicht nicht alle aber viele um ihre
kinder und enkel aber zugleich muss man
ihnen sagen nein ihr könnt auch diese
demokratie so gestaltet und jetzt gehen
sie einfach mal nach hongkong oder nach
belarus und fragen weil dort die jungen
und daher werden die ihnen seien auch
menschen wenn man es doch hätten wie in
deutschland das ist ja das problem von
uns menschen wir schätzen die dinge erst
wenn sie gefährdet sind oder wenn wir
sie nicht haben
wissen diejenigen die nicht wählen gehen
die demokratie zu wenig zu schätzen oder
macht es sich die politik damit zu
einfach wälzt sie so nur ihre
verantwortung auf die nichtwähler ab
natürlich gibt es diejenigen die sich
einfach nicht interessieren oder die
nicht bereit sind kompromisse einzugehen
und ich glaube auch wir machen es uns
oft zu leicht brechen den stab über die
politik und die politiker
[Musik]
aber es kann nicht sein dass in
deutschland im wohlhabenden die
zufriedenen er zur wahl gehen und die
unzufriedenen die die sich abgehängt
fühlen die eigentlich veränderung
feuchten sich immer mehr von der
demokratie abwenden
und es kann auch nicht sein dass fast
drei viertel der jungen menschen glauben
politik interessiere sich nicht für ihre
anliegen
das gefühl nicht gehört zu werden ist
ein gift für jede demokratie
[Musik]
[Applaus]